in news that will surprise absolutely no
one but yet is still being miss reported
somehow we now have eight Trump staffers
who attended the Trump rally in Tulsa on
Saturday or who were there that day some
of them were actually sent home early
because they got the virus who have
tested positive for coronavirus remember
that on Saturday we learned that six
Trump staffers tested positive for
coronavirus Trump was furious that the
news got out that they had tested
positive we now got a new statement from
the Trump campaign which says that quote
after another round of testing for
campaign staff in Tulsa two additional
members of the advance team tested
positive for the corona virus these
staff members attended the rally but
were wearing masks during the entire
event upon the positive tests the
campaign immediately activated
established quarantine and contact
tracing protocols so in the midst of all
of this two Secret Service agents also
tested positive for a corona virus so we
have to clarify the misinformation we've
been dealing with this virus now for
what four months that we know of in
reality even that we knew about even
longer in reality and you're immediately
seeing every nonsense reaction that you
can imagine from Trump estándar people
on the right to this news so first of
all this line about the last two
staffers got the virus even though they
wore masks during the entire event this
is causing some people to say see look
masks don't even do anything
masks do work we have a new study that
says the faster countries obtained
widespread numbers of masks the faster
they suppress the spread of corona virus
also remember that the rally didn't
require masks so whether masks do or
don't work which they do the rally goers
weren't wearing masks but the most
important element of confusion is that
nobody is saying any of these staffers
caught the virus at the rally in fact
six of the eight staffers who were
tested positive were part of the
adventure they were all part of the
advance team but six of them left before
the rally even started in other words
clearly they got the
sometime last week incubated it for you
know 48 hours a few days and then tested
positive on Saturday and were sent home
these other two staffers we have no
reason to believe that they actually
caught this at the rally not to mention
they could have caught it in Tulsa but
not at the rally where they were wearing
masks and instead somewhere else we have
something called an incubation period so
right away this is bad news right that
this is more proof the rally shouldn't
have happened because the rally didn't
require people to wear masks and you
have these low information trumpets who
say this is proof you don't even need
masks because they don't work no that's
that's not the right story that's not
the right story at all now what we
should be seeing as the takeaway from
news that eight Trump staffers plus two
Secret Service agents caught the virus
around the time of the rally is that the
rally was a really bad idea
with 6,200 people there plus countless
staff and law enforcement and others
what are the odds that these eight
people were the only people in the place
with the virus that day let's grant that
these eight didn't catch it at the rally
because I don't think they did there are
obviously other people who were there
that day who also were incubating the
virus and they had caught it elsewhere
and nobody was required to wear masks
now that being said no method is 100%
foolproof right masks are useful if
everybody's wearing them that
dramatically reduces the chance of
spread but it's just a numbers game if
you put 6,200 people indoors even if
they all wear masks someone is likely to
catch the virus through one of those
less likely contagion methods we've
learned over the last few months surface
contagion is not that common right early
on there was a lot about sanitizing and
bleaching your vegetables and food and
boxes that you know take out all of this
stuff turns out that the surface
contagion is actually quite quite rare
but if you have 6,200 people together
you can have a one in six thousand
incident and that still means someone
catches the virus through a surface
contact
someone takes their mask off for a
second and sneezes on a door handle
someone 15 second later opens the door
and then has to adjust their mask and
touches their eyes and their you've got
it right even a very unlikely event when
you have sixty two hundred people
together becomes far more likely this is
where the rules come from or guidelines
come from about it's better if you're
not in groups of more than ten why
because with fewer than ten people a one
in a thousand contagion method is very
unlikely to happen with 6,200 people a
one in a thousand contagion contagion
method or risk is likely to now have six
instances of contagion I think that most
of you sort of understand the math when
will we know the effect of the rally on
cases in Oklahoma we may never know we
have to understand that because unless
we get contact tracing news because
cases are exploding in general in
Oklahoma we may never really know the
effect of that one rally as you can see
in Oklahoma we're putting a case chart
up on the screen the cases were already
spiking from the day before the rally
and they've continued a spike it takes
about 10 to 14 days to know the full
effect of contagion from any particular
event so we may never really know
because cases are spiking in Oklahoma in
general now some good news from here in
Massachusetts we had the protests
against police brutality two weeks ago
almost everybody was wearing masks and
massachusetts numbers continue to
improve so what we are learning again is
the masks do work which we knew already
and that is reassuring to say the least